true well let's talk about the chain
what's happening speaking of censorship
we got this story from tim cast elon
musk is still committed to twitter
purchase after announcing deal was on
hold musk said he would defeat the spam
bots or die trying a cause for due
diligence to discover the true daily
active user numbers in the deal i'm
going to give you the quick version i
think elon musk knew there was fraud i
believe twitter is possible has has
defrauded its shareholders we know that
they've lied i'm sorry i'm sorry
we know they've published false user
numbers on more than one occasion
they've apologized for it
let me show you something interesting if
we go to socialblade and look at little
ole me we can see that on april 26th i
gained but just about 20 000 followers
the next day about 40 000. the next day
about seven thousand gaining all of
these followers strange right at the
same time barack obama loses three
hundred thousand at the same time katy
perry loses two hundred thousand
why are
celebrities and left and progressives
losing followers but people on the
libertarian freedom whatever right side
are gaining followers i'll tell you what
i think
that's here's the dates the 26th 27th
28th the 29th was a friday
monday was the second and what news
broke on the second
twitter estimates fake accounts comprise
less than five percent of users filing
on may 2nd here's what they say
in a filing on monday may 2nd
they say it was 5 percent here's my
here's my opinion after looking at all
of this information the week prior they
reinstated as many writing accounts as
possible to create human users and
banned as many bots as possible to
reduce the number of bots so they could
bring the number of bots per user way
way down i think elon musk knew they
were doing that
i think he's forcing them to give him
the data now that he's locked in this
deal or lose a billion dollars
and if they given the information on all
these users he can come out and be like
they defrauded me they defrauded you and
they defrauded all the shareholders
i think
twitter
believes in a healthy conversation and
they're trying to socially engineer this
country and people who use twitter
around the world by making it seem like
pro america and libertarian values are
not prominent
and woke leftist ideas are so they
create fake accounts or someone does and
they ban counts that are pro-america
then the switch the flip happens we
watched it happen
then they release their report on their
bots elon's going to get that data
because they have to reveal it to him
and then we'll see what happens yeah i'm
curious what his next step would be
after that is this just something that
he
does to expose them or does he try to
come in and alter the price maybe
twitter blows up maybe it just it's gone
i mean i don't know
that this is true right what i'm saying
is if you look at the fact that leftist
loss followers libertarian right maga
whatever you want to call it gained
followers that's that's that's
algorithmic people have tried claiming
the left is leaving and the right's
joining no that's ridiculous because if
you look at the data as i pointed out
the last time we talked about it on
monday the day they announced the deal
was happening
no one joined twitter they're lying
that's not true the data does not
suggest that the data suggests twitter
made weird algorithmic changes and then
the next week monday they issued their
filing on bot accounts
clearly they were manipulating the
numbers
it's scandal it's a scandal
it's it's john got him
i agree with you actually i think what
you said is mostly true i would say if i
was newsguard uh i don't know that he
knew they were about
politifact
i don't know that he knew that there
were bots i think he highly
he he he thought that there were he had
a good feeling a hunch i'll tell you my
my greater theory
one day elon musk is on twitter
and he's like i really like this babylon
b i'm going to tweet to them and then he
does and then all of a sudden it goes
new notification and he looks and it's
himself
trying to convince himself to engage in
a crypto scam
because you ever see those first thing
he thought of was time travel and he's
like hasn't been invented yet he's like
could i have come back from the future
to sell bitcoin to myself yes but unless
let me check and then he like does some
math and he's like
this is a bot and then he probably
complained and they did nothing
so there's a really famous uh
like botting scam where elon musk bots
will tweet at people to get him to give
crypto
elon probably was like this is me stop
and he says okay i'm gonna get rid of
this stuff so i think he knows something
was going on i also think
elon probably saw the manipulation with
sock puppet accounts a stock puppet
account is when one person runs multiple
accounts
i'm willing to bet
the left runs tons of sock puppet
accounts
where one activist will have 20 accounts
and they'll spam you to make it seem
like everyone is dog piling you and
hates you you'll say something and then
you'll get 50 responses with like you're
ugly you're gross you're stupid you're
lame to try and trick you and force you
to changing your opinion then twitter
bans people on the right so no one can
come to your aid i think i think that's
what's happening that's my opinion on
what's happening so you're saying that
i'm not ugly stupid and lame like
is it john
no you're not i'm the exception yeah
it's it's it's a form of grooming
what they do is
when 30 people tell you
hey man you know concern trolling like
i'm a big fan but i think you're not
right on this one you should change your
opinion and then the only thing you see
is people saying you're wrong about it
weaker-minded people might be like okay
i better i better change my position on
this they call it al groom rhythmic ah
i don't know if i said that right i
tried yeah i gotta write it down first
you know i noticed something when i was
in college which is that when i got
people who are
really
outwardly left-leaning
alone and had conversations with them
where we weren't with other students
they would generally
say things that you would not expect a
left-winger to say so maybe i'd you know
run into them somewhere outside of
school or we would just be chatting
outside of class and
whenever current events came up they
would almost inevitably say something
about any given issue that
that would basically get someone
screamed at by any other left winger for
not being left-wing enough
and they'd even say things like yeah i'm
gonna be honest like i do think the left
is kind of gone off the deep end in
certain ways and part of me wondered if
that was because
they were being sincere about their
values because they were surrounded by
other left-wing people
part of me also wondered if that was
because they understood or got the vibe
that they were talking to a more
conservative person and they're just
social chameleons who need to fit in
with whoever they're having a
conversation with i don't know but
in my experience
it it's funny like in my experience
people uh are yeah even left-wing people
are not as far to left when they're not
in a group it's like as soon as they get
around other people they're mao uh but
when they're by themselves they're like
they turn into dave rubin i think
they're scared
they're being
groomed with like
the language and everything that you see
like the media so they're scared of like
not going all the way because if not
then what would they side with they will
side with um the maggot king the the
ultra mega the fascists the the kkk so
it's like they feel like they have to
constantly move
further to the left to be able to match
that even though it may not match it uh
what they think but it's like for the
bigger cause because if they don't do it
if they don't stay together if they
don't stay united then um you know big
bad orange guy is going to be back in
the white house and then everybody is
going to
uh be put in camps or something so they
have to stick together and to me you
know
that that's it's like zombies yep yep
and it is a fallacy to think that in
order to not be part of group a you have
to join another group you don't have to
join a group absolutely the funniest
thing i i love a lot is when these
lefties will post on twitter they'll be
like i'm not in a brainwashed cult like
you are and it's like they're the group
that voted in lockstep to fund the war
in ukraine and then the other side of
this is
former liberals traditional liberals
conservatives you've got the far-right
you know laissez-faire capitalist types
you've got libertarian centrists like
there's this big eclectic group of
people who all disagree with each other
who are sitting in rooms and having
conversations you're all in the room all
patting each other on the back saying
they're the cult
i went on facebook a couple nights ago
i've got a very interesting social media
array because i uh most of my facebook
friends from 2007 89 when i was in la as
an actor very liberal now most of my
twitter followers are people that watch
this show so it's more or less
conservative i don't want to put you in
a box guys you're whatever you want to
be but when i go on on twitter or on
facebook they're like you know
pro-choice when it comes to the abortion
thing and they're like they think oh
that's just what they think and it's the
same kind of crap when we're on the show
we're talking about them
whatever whenever it comes up about they
it's the same terminology and the same
weird that the people don't even know
who they are they're just using this
term except we're right of course you
always we always think we are don't we
no but we are well everyone thinks
they're the good guy man yeah be careful
about we are about categorizing other
people the data has repeatedly shown
that moderates and conservatives consume
media from the left and know the
left-wing argument but the left doesn't
do the other i think there are instances
in history where like the nazis were a
radical left leftist organization i've
heard you know and they were
indoctrinating kids and the people that
stood against that turned out to be on
the right side of history it is possible
that
and i think a lot of when it comes to
objective morality a lot of what we're
talking about is real like it's
important to protect the children let me
let me
clarify this point as to why we're right
and they're not
you have as i mentioned traditional
liberals people like you know me i used
to i voted for obama in 08 i was from
the city and now i'm like hey man i
don't like this woke stuff i want free
speech you have devout catholics like
sheamus very pro-life conservative and
we disagree on a lot of those elements
but we agree on so much more when it
comes to what's reality what's true you
have journalists like matt taibi
a liberal outright who's like yeah this
ukraine stuff with joe biden is messed
up you have glenn greenwald a
progressive you have jimmy dore how is
it that all of these people from actual
economic far left to laissez-faire
capitalist anarchists or people like
people like luke rodkowski all can can
come together and agree and point at
the left and say they're wrong
as i mentioned when when you look at
that voting block for ukraine war
funding and every single democrat is
voting yes on one of the largest war
packages ever and the republicans are
all in disagreement i'm like something
is wrong when the anti-war progressive
leftists like aoc and the squad are
voting in lockstep for war
they are a cult yeah it's the liberal
economic order let's and let me tell you
ian
you say they say the same thing about us
i i completely agree with similar
terminology
it's identical pretty much it's hard to
tell who i thought they were talking
about they like what we were last night
i'm like oh my god except we were right
you know why covington jesse smilet
russiagate ukraine gate ghost of kiev
trayvon martin george floyd the list
goes on military industrial complex has
controlled the media and if you don't
know that then you're you're getting
sucked up into it i don't even know if
it's that you know i don't know what's
going on i think twitter was playing
weird manipulation engineering games the
fact is i remember i had this moment in
you know 2018 and i'm thinking you know
i watch these lefty these left-wing
presenters and they're saying the exact
same thing and then i'm like but that's
weird
they're wrong about the covington kids
well that's weird bill maher a week
after the story was debunked comes out
and still maintains the lie well that's
weird russiagate was debunked and
they're still saying it was true
they called rand paul a russian agent
again it's just the lies the
misinformation the manipulation they set
up a disinformation czar this woman
who's published repeated false
information and she wants the right to
control the flow of information so i'm
sorry if you've got an eclectic bunch of
people with all differing world views
and differing political opinions but we
can see what's true and what's not you
have another side that believes every
single lie every time i guess why i
brought it up and i know this when i did
it because what you're saying shame is
people when they're in that group they
do become radicalized but when they're
alone and you communicate with them
people aren't so crazy like people kind
of get together and can understand so
like that's why i'm reticent to say they
because when that person is over here
they're we and and it's you know they
get it it's the funniest thing is man
when i was arguing on facebook with some
people
and i said it's the weirdest thing if
michael malus points this out a lot if
you disagree with anything that is part
of their tribe they immediately assume
you're a trump supporting far-right maga
cult or whatever
and it's like i've actually commented on
people's posts agreeing with them and
they'll immediately say it's it's the
joke someone's like i like pancakes and
i'll be like you know the interesting
thing about pancakes they have a lot of
carbs and so you're a waffle person
waffles are about i never said i liked
waffles dude so when i comment on
someone's post about pro-life
they'll make they'll make a point about
conservatives and i'll say
i don't think that's the actual
conservative argument the response i get
is you want to control women's bodies
and put them in chains and i'm like
i don't want to do any of that i don't
understand
it's a cult bro are there
ultra maga trump cultists of course do
they have any institutional power no are
they that are they are they relatively
large in number not really
yeah so what we'll see with the left is
they'll take very basic concepts which
legitimately are binary such as sex and
they'll try to break it up into a
million different gradients and say it
exists on a spectrum when it doesn't
then when it comes to politics they'll
basically say it's binary either you're
with us or you're some far-right trump
supporter you're also a nazi there's
there's no room for any kind of gradient
there on their own side they sort of try
to get into like some nuance because
they'll claim that you know someone like
bernie sanders is really a moderate and
so we have this very vast spectrum on
our own side even though they're really
only catering to like 10 percent of the
population in totality when you're
looking at progressives they were
manufacturing public support i think
that um
it's sort of like uh
something that there there's a third
component to this which is you have the
the right and you have the left but you
also have the globalists which they owe
alliance to neither the left nor the
right so they sort of like co-opted the
liberal and the progressive movement and
everything that they do is according to
the globalist agenda like they want you
know no borders they won't know there's
no that um
they want to sort of like in everything
everything the the global supply chain
whatever it is more uh trade with china
whatever and a lot of these things that
they have been pushing is not
um not something that the left would
have wanted
even five to three years ago or even two
months ago but they feel that they have
to keep pushing it because they have to
meet the globalist
sort of like
end goal and hopefully leftists and and
liberals and classic liberals they're
going to start
realizing that um
like stop it they're using you
i think they will
the economy is going to force people to
evolve classic liberals are already out
because classic liberal is a right-wing
position tradition traditional liberals
were social liberals so they were like
center left and there's like there's
like a little bit of a difference but
it's like you know they're both centrist
i think these people uh on the left
aren't
feeling like they have to lock it walk
in lockstep with like the davos group or
anything
it's zombies you know like we're
mentioning the young turks they just
make they make stuff up they lie all the
time maybe it's inept ineptitude maybe
they're just like this look at clicks i
mean if you look at their videos the
thumbs down are crazy like 50 60 percent
i'm like how do you view those still
because i don't yeah
oh cool i can't rationalize it like i
can't understand to me i'm trying to me
i'm thinking
they're being brainwashed the the
globalists at the top are like pushing
propaganda and media and brainwashing
these people because i can't rationalize
how you would you know like these things
for kids how you would you know
uh come after kids like that like to me
if if you were to put me in a time
machine
like 10 years ago and you show me that
i'll be ready to you know start a
revolution and i'm not even you know so
it's to me it's like
go ahead no no no no continue continue
i'm sorry i just wanted to say it's sort
of like how how quickly the needle is
moving
and it's it's just out of control
um so i have to find like a way to
rationalize this behavior like why
they're doing this
and and i don't know i don't have that
answer yet i think you're on to it
though i think it's a global agenda i
mean you look at how much stuff vanguard
owns and like they're being schwab like
they're being uh brainwashed
yeah there is
a bike definitely by the liberal media i
don't like using that word liberal i
don't want to give that power to that
word because it is post-modernist i'm
i'm i'm trying to understand i'm not an
expert of post-modernism it's the idea
that you'd say i'm a human i'd be like
no i'm actually a embodiment of cells
and they're like no i'm actually an
energy field you're describing none of
them yeah that i was i went through that
i'm like out of the cult now i was in la
as the actor getting ready to be the
next big thing it was disgusting and
then they were all over me sexually it
was so gross
and jordan peterson has talked a lot
about post-modernism he points the
finger at it it's a confusing idea which
is why it hasn't caught as much hot
traction as it needs to
and it's a social movement that started
in the mid-20s
19th 20th century basically yeah i just
wanted to issue a small correction to
myself earlier i described them as 10 of
the population according to pew research
they're six percent but even that figure
isn't perfect because as i'm looking at
how they define it when they talk about
the progressive left they say 88 of
people on the progressive left say that
greater social acceptance of tr of
people who are transgender is a good
thing for the us i mean for only 88 of
them to be saying that when the type of
progressive leftists were talking about
would say
yeah 88 of people uh who would be who
would fall into this progressive left
category which they say makes up six
percent of the public 12.
yeah and so that's what i'm saying so
this this progressive left group this is
a very small group of people because of
that six percent of the public
only 88 of them this group defined as
progressive left say that more
transgender acceptance is good for
society whereas my understanding is the
progressive leftists we're talking about
would say anyone who answered that
question is anything other than yes is
not a progressive in fact they're far
right thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you